ابنيه مدمره ومنازل مهجوره واشخاص بلا
ماوى واخرون يودعون احبائهم تحت التراب
مشهد مريب خلفه اعصار ايرما المدمر في جزر
الكريب وشرق ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
فاثار الرعب في جزر قريبه فرنسيه
وبريطانيه وفي كوبا فما قصته في السابع
والعشرين من اغسطس للعام 2017 بدا اعصار
ايرما كموجه ضعيفه بزخات مطريه وعواصف
رعديه ظهرت قباله ساحل غرب افريقيا لكن
هذه الموجه تطورت تدريجيا لتتحول الى
اعصار من الفئه الخامسه وصل الى ذروته في
الخامس من سبتمبر مع بلوغه جزر ليوارد
استمر الاعصار بالتحرك فوق الجزر
الكاريبيه الصغيره فيما بلغت سرعته 156
ميلا مع وصوله جزيره فلوريدا كيز الواقعه
جنوب شرق الولايه الامريكيه مع استمرار
العاصفه حمل اليوم الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
تطورا غير متوقع عندما وصل الاعصاران
كاتيا الى المنطقه ما تسبب باندماج
الاعاصير الثلاثه في اول حدث تلتقي فيه
ثلاثه اعاصير متزامنه منذ عام 2010
بالمنطقه ما فاقم من التاثيرات مع تواصل
الهطول المطري ارتفع منسوب البحار لتجرف
المياه القوارب وتحول الشوارع الى انهار
اجتاحت الرياح العاصفه المدن الكبرى وحملت
معها كل ما وجدته في طريقها فاقتلعت
الاشجار ودمرت حدائق المنازل ومرافق
المنشات الحيويه
خلال الساعات الاولى تقطعت السبل بالكثير
من السكان والسياح ما دفع السلطات لاصدار
اوامر اخلاء لخمسه ملايين الف شخص في
الثاني عشر من سبتمبر تراجعت حده الاعصار
بانتقاله الى جزيره ميزوري تاركا خلفه
سلسله من الدمار المميت في الجزر الصغيره
والمدن التي عصفت بها بما في ذلك جاكسون
فال وفلوريدا بولايه
في جزيره باربودا وحدها لحقت اضرار بنحو
95% من المباني في الجزيره وذكرت مصادر
رسميه ان ربع المنازل في ولايه فلوريدا
تعرض لاضرار جسيمه فيما بقي ملايين
الاشخاص بدون كهرباء في اعقاب العاصفه بين
العديد من الاعاصير التي شهدها حوض المحيط
الاطلسي كان اعصار ايرما اقوى اعصار عرفته
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه منذ اعصار
كاترينا
[موسيقى]